you have a full section in your book on
on foot fetishes I do I do yeah which is
funny because I don't know anything
about Focus yeah like I can't I'm not
King shaming anybody but like there's
nothing sexual about feet to me at all
like I just don't get it I don't but I
mean listen to people like things it's
good you know but yeah I I have had
clients that have
odd fetishes or sexual proclivities or
things they want to do and they don't
share it with their partner at all and
then they find an outlet for it because
they try to go without it and that
doesn't work so they try to find some
other outlet for it and then that's
interpreted as a betrayal and it creates
distance and people split up and of
course everybody likes to have like a
you know a bad guy to blame it on so
when you say Well why'd you guys get
divorced oh because he secretly had a
foot fetish and he was on these message
boards like making people well it gives
you an easy answer as to why the two of
you split up but I don't think you know
most divorces have such simple answers
is it was a foot thing but I also think
too like listen if you've got a partner
and we all do stuff that we're not super
into because we're in a relationship and
that's what part of it is like do you
really want to go see that chick flick
do you really want to eat at this
restaurant you really want to go to her
cousin's wedding no but you know part of
being a relationship is okay if you're
into this I'm gonna
pretend this song's a good song you know
even though it's not my favorite song
and and I think
I I just don't know we've turned sex I
mean sex has been so politicized in
recent years maybe it always was but I I
think we've made it into something where
we can't just I don't know I'm not in
defeat but if the woman I love was like
you know I'm really in defeat like I
really want to do stuff with your feet
I'd be like all right I can pretend I'm
into that like for it's not gonna kill
me yeah no I'm not gonna be able to make
it a centerpiece of our coupling but you
know like yeah I can send them into feed
if you want I don't personally have any
fetishes that are outside of the um
the normal discourse as a divorce lawyer
I get to experience the whole Spectrum
but if I like if I was into like furries
for example yeah I don't know how I
would initiate the conversation with my
partner about that
but but frame the question the other
direction if you were into furries yeah
how do you prevent your partner from
knowing anything about that
that feels like a real you'd have to
make a conscious choice to not let your
partner know sure sure so so I I don't
think either of those is a particularly
palatable or easy proposition but a lot
of people live life hiding some part of
themselves yeah quite unsuccessfully
like it the the second order effects of
that are very rarely positive sure I
don't I don't think I've ever met
someone and went yeah I really hid this
huge part of myself for an extended
period of time that's the best thing
that happened it's I'm really glad I'm
really glad I stayed in the closet as
long as I did you know it really worked
out like it rarely does it's a question
of how long can you hold it off yeah
like I know gay men who stayed in the
closet for 40 years 50 years of their
lives
and then they had a successful second
chapter as a gay man
I've had clients like that
do they regret that they were in the
closet no because they were married they
had kids like they had experiences
they're glad they had
but with their advice to a young person
in their 20s and 30s who's gay be stay
in the closet because then you can have
a wife and some kids and then you can
come out when you're 50 or 60 and have a
second chapter no they would say you
know be who you are don't be afraid you
know as you were talking I'm trying to
think of because I I'm publicly and
privately I'm the exact same person I
try to be the exact same person so I
usually try to make sure there's nothing
to hide but I I was trying to come up
with a Conor example for you for if
there's good things
um well I mean there could be like past
relationships like if I you know slept
with thousands of women or something
like this maybe that you wanna
put that to the side well you don't want
to be in there's a difference between
being honest about something and being
indelicate about it right you know like
I I I think we all do this with lovers
like any of us who've been in more than
one relationship
you would not you know at the end of sex
be like that was the third best sex I've
ever had you know like you that's it's
just in delicate it's rude you know so
so I don't think it's a matter of like
total Candor at all times
but I I think if you were using the
furry example I'm not picking on furries
I just think if if that is a proclivity
that is anything other than a passing
thought like it's something that you
just keep coming back to
then you're making a conscious decision
to withhold it from your partner and
what is that out of I mean I would say
it's probably out of fear I'm not a
psychologist but probably out of fear
fear that they would reject you that
they okay well now
see I I genuinely believe that that
this
you know
I I'm I'm very conflicted in my
religious Faith but I
I don't know that I believe in the devil
but if there was a devil
I think his principal function would be
to convince us that we are so beastial
that God couldn't love us
it would be to convince us that we're
awful
and that we should just lean into the
awfulness and I know the the greatest
low points of my life came whenever I
just went you know what I'm just I'm
just awful I might as well just behave
awfully
and
I I really believe
that
when you don't
when you push down parts of yourself
like your sexuality
like your insecurities your true
feelings from your romantic partner the
person who's supposed to be your you
know your number one
you are making sure you will never feel
their love
because they don't love you
they love the you you've presented to
them which you know in your heart is not
the authentic honest real you
and so if you know you're super into
furries
and you don't tell your partner about
that
and your partner says I love you so much
and you know what I love one of the
things I love about us is we have such
great sexual chemistry you'll never feel
that love because you know yeah that's
not true though she doesn't know she
doesn't know that actually I'm not
really satisfied and there is this thing
that I want that I know I can't even
tell her because I'm so ashamed like
that doesn't feel like a good option to
me
yeah yeah so that kind of vulnerability
is essential to intimacy you know I'm
prone to Jujitsu metaphors and this is
one of the first conversations where I
can actually use them because the person
I'm talking to is a jiu jitsu person but
and people should know that you are a
quote-unquote Jiu-Jitsu person you have
been Afflicted with the I am a brown
belt under Marcella Garcia and I am like
a seven year brown belt now so which is
the right way to be a brombo well and
also I am I am you know late middle aged
middleweight and moderately talented so
I'm I'm and training it at that Academy
with so many incredibly talented people
and training in New York City where
there's so many unbelievably talented
people you're you're constantly humble
and feeling like you should just be
wearing a blue belt all the time
um but but a lot of I think as you know
and as most most people who practice Jiu
Jitsu know you start to sort of see Jiu
Jitsu and everything I genuinely believe
that in
love
you you have to give something to get
something you have to CR everything you
do creates a vulnerability you know
every every move you make in jiu jitsu
creates opportunity and creates
vulnerability and so you have to be
willing to create vulnerabilities in
order to get any leverage in order to
get any progress and any way to move the
position you know you don't want a
marriage that's just two people both in
50 50. you know like you're just sitting
in that car doing nothing you know you
you wanna you want it to actually move
along
yeah I mean that's the way I see love in
relationships this you should take that
leap of vulnerability give the other
person the option to destroy you
what you have to expose and that's
that's the part that I think is is
um hard for everyone you know is is to
expose yourself in that way but that's
what I mean even when I said about
getting a dog or having a child like
love loving anything
is tremendously courageous
because it's terrifying
and it's only Brave if you're scared if
you're not scared you know it's not
brave it's just stupidity it's just you
know it's it's it's bravery when you're
afraid and you do the thing anyway and
so love is like yeah it's scary like it
I don't care who you are like you know
being you know in the Jiu Jitsu
Community like I'm around you know as
you are all like incredibly tough people
like physically tough people mentally
tough people but you know I've seen some
of those people taken down yeah by a 120
pound woman you know not not not from a
grappling perspective but they are taken
apart Yeah by a woman in their life and
and vice versa I've seen men you know
who like it really is shocking how much
leverage we give to our romantic
partners and how little discussion we
really genuine discussion we really have
about it how much we really are ever
trained to think about it you know
there's nothing in school that teaches
us about it so much of literature and
art is an idealized version of it
so little of it is is real